nowadays if you want to interact with
the TV program you pick up the phone or
you text and you vote and if you want a
lot of information you go on the web but
it wasn't always so before the web got
mainstream what you would do is you
would send a stamped addressed envelope
if you wanted a big packet information
this means for anyone born after say
about 2000 you take an envelope you
would address it to yourself you'll put
a stamp on it you'll put it in another
envelope and you'll post that envelope
off the TV company and a couple of weeks
later they would get it open it put
their information in the envelope you'd
written to yourself send it back to you
and then finally a month later you would
actually have some information from the
TV company now in the early 90s before
the web came along someone did have an
idea a couple of British programmes on
ITV yo-yo bet influence check it out MC
crane kick it one time I'm sorry
experimented with something called a day
to blast home video recorders were now a
thing so over the credits of their shows
right at the end they would put
information in each frame over the
credits so the home viewers could record
the whole thing and then pause through
at their leisure which was a good idea
in theory in practice it was a bad idea
because that web came along and it was a
bad idea because home video recorders
aren't nearly good enough to manage that
they stutter they create artifacts they
have all sorts of problems but who knows
if the web hadn't come along with maybe
maybe even now we have a data bust at
the end of each of our TV shows and that
is something you might not have known